コメント欄で校長が授教の話する時に古いとか
考え方が古臭いっていうのをたくさん頂いたのでまずちょっとその話からお願いします。
はい。
古いと悪いの意味は分かってるんかな?授況をやる時にこれ自という事んだ。これほど授況を解釈するのにありがたいものもまたないんや。漢字のね、出来方漢字もどんどんどんどん変わってくるからね。
進歩してくる。その進歩の仕方とか綺麗に
書いてある。だから授況をやってみようと
思う人はまずこれかいな。この辞書見ると
我々理系でも満足するわ。これによる古い
これの意味やね。古いというのを否定語に
使う。今でも否定語に使っるやろ。考え方
が古いんだから考え方を否定しとるわけ。
アンチの方ですから
ね。全部左翼だ。は新しいわけやから古い
のを否定しないと自分を肯定できんやろ。
だから古いのを否定するんだ。だけど奴ら
が正しいという証拠はどこにもないやない
か。
じゃあ古いから。古いというのは銃下口の
口。これはねって言うんやな。王様がこれ
どうしようなという政策を考える。で、
そのせ、考えた制作を当時だから木に書い
たり竹に書いたりするな、木カとかち感。
それをこういう入れ物に入れるんだ。で、
蓋をして巫がその横でずっと天に祈るんだ
と巫がだんだんなんか捨り状態になって
くんのね。踊り出したり叫んだりする。
そうすると神と更新ができるんだ。で、神
と更新ができたら神がこの際に降りてくる
。降りてきた状態を足神が足から降りて
くるけどね。足巫女がそいつを見てみると
神様はこう言ってるというのが出てくるん
だ。で、その通りの政治をやるとうまく
いく。これが再生一致。巫女が決める。
これうまくいっとったんだと。それを人間
がやり出す。ヨーロッパでも中国なんかで
もそうやね。やり出すとダメになるんだ。
神の声聞いてないんやね。で、1
個質問で神の声を聞くとまくいくっていうのが、ま、校長がつもおっしゃる科学とか理系からするとちょっとどうなのかなって思うんですけど、これ何か補足とかありますか?
神の声と思っとったのが実は巫女の考えやったんだ。しかも必になって理性を消して考えるということは本能で考えるということなんだ。本能は正しいんだからその考えは正しいんだ。
だから再生一致が成り立つな科学でしょう
。本能が全ということなんや。口はそう
正しいという意味。上の銃は盾なんだ。
こういう四角い盾ほ剣盾盾で受けて剣で
攻撃する盾守るだから正しさを守るという
のが古い
ということは正しい精神な。正しい精神と
いうのはそれで行動するとちゃんと正しい
結果が出る。だからそいつをずっと使い
続けるんだ。その精神を。で、これ古く
なるんじゃん。もしこれが左翼の言うよう
に間違っとったらすぐ捨てちゃうやろ。
古くならんのだ。だから大体古くなった
ものというのは正しいものと思っても
間違いない。古いというのは正しさを守る
という意味なんだから褒め言葉だから俺の
考えが古い言うたら褒めてくれて
ありがとうよということや。お前はバカだ
。新しいことが正しいなんて愚かにも信じ
とる。まだ新しいことというのはまだ実績
がないわけよ。正しいかどうかわからん。
もしお前の言うことが正しいならやがて
古くなる。ね、
アンチの方のこう補足というか、ま、令和の時代で、ま、今は時代も変わってるんだから凸の理論は通用しないっていうのが、ま、彼らの言いたいことだと思うんですけど。
バカ言うな。人間は変わってないよ。そうやろ。本能はずっと一緒だ。人間はもう進化しないんだ。なぜならば自分で進歩できるんだから進化する必要がないんや。だからお前みたいなバカが進化するかもしれんね。進化せんとついていけんやろ。
だけどそれはおそらく進歩やで。進化って
いうのは長い世代で起こることであって
進歩は自分1台で起こることやからね。
これができるから人間が素晴らしくなった
んじゃん。からもういい加減なことで人を
批判するな、このバカ野郎。分かっても
ないくせにできません。できてから文句
言ってこい。
ついでにちょっとアンチコメントが話題だったので授教と仏教の動画で特にそうなんですけど、ま、こいつの解釈は間違ってるっていうのが未だに結構コメントでありまして、それ人たちにこうどう反論してこいとか何か言いたいこととかありますか?
科学的にやってくれ。どこがどう違うのか。それとね、今までのあんたは自分の解釈というのを自分で作ったんかな?人が作ったのをそのまま言ってない。
自分で作ったんなら立派や。だけど人の
解釈をそのまま言っとるんだったらその人
の解釈が正しいかどうかを1回テストせい
やな。総戦とあそこにあ、書いてあった。
この前のリ廻テンションの時なんかそうや
ね。あの本にこう書いてあったからお前は
間違っとる言うてということはその本が
正しいという証拠があるんかね。特にリ廻
転職なんて証拠出せんやろ。彼らの言う人
で天章はそれが正しいって言うんならお前
人間になる前何やったんやこれ人間終わっ
たら何になるんかな?言ってみえいいよ。
できたら動画でもあったら最高やなから
そういうわけのわからんこと。あれは自分
の望みでもあるわな。死んだっておしまい
じゃなくという風に思いたい。次がまた
あるんだと。それはどうかな。帰ってきた
人はいないな。死にかけの時になんか言っ
た人もいない。みんなもそれでおしまいや
ないか。で、ずっと何億人とね、特にね、
リ廻転生なんて人間というのは今どれだけ
の人数になっちまったんや。何十億という
人間やで。それがみんなネズミになったら
どうするよ。地球滅びちゃうでと。今まで
ずっと生まれてきた生物がみんな残っとる
はずやな。他の格好でどうやって残っとる
んや。そうよ。とっから証明してけよ。
そうじゃなかったら信用するんじゃね。
証明できないことはね。
授況だとAっていうのは礼儀正しさのこと
を解いているま、マナーとかの話であって
動画で言っている内容は間違っている
みたいなの結構ありましたね。霊というの
は自分の能力を正しく知ること。論語の中
の例えば霊のよう和を持って遠としとなす
。これ同解釈する霊の使い方はって書いて
あるやないか。霊を正しく使うと和を作る
ことができる。さらに人間が進歩するため
に例が必要である。この意味が分かるのか
?霊というのは能力を正しく理解すること
。まず自分の能力を正しく理解せ。俺は
こういう風なんだ。この程度なんだ。こう
いうことができるんだ。そうすると偉い人
の能力が自分より上だということが分かる
。自分との比較やむ。そうすると能力の差
がある。作家見とっても野球見とっても
そうやろ。能力に明らかに差があるやない
か。能力の低いやつは能力の高いやつと
自分を比べて恥ができる。恥という重要な
不快感だ。恥が人間を進歩させる。論語に
書いてある。恥がないと進歩しないよ。
そのために霊を作る。で、もっと具体的に
はで行動すると進歩する。だから霊のよ、
霊の使い方は和を作ること。作った輪で
行動してみ。ほら進歩しただろう。これが
その読み方ないんや。どれでもいいからの
解説書ってきて呼んでみ。そこがどういう
風に役してある?お前が納得するような役
が出とるのか?あんなもんに納得するん
やったら俺はダメなやつで必ず授況という
のは実学であるというとこがあるんだ。
そいつを使える。正しく正しく使ったら
進歩するな。だからまず自分の解釈をで
行動して進歩して見せる。そうしたらその
解釈は正しいということになる。霊もそう
やで。霊はだこだと頭ひねくり回しとっ
たって進歩せんやろ。それで行動し
なけりゃダメなんだ。そういう風に使うと
授況は素晴らしいもんやで。
この動画見てる方にもなんか骨のある
アンチコメントだったらこうやって
取り上げて校長に読んでもらおうと思っ
てるので、またあのコメント欄で是非
書き込んでください。自分の意見を言い
たければ自分で作れ意見をね、意見を言う
のが大事だったら意見を作るのはもっと
大事やで。しの子の言う。俺はどうやって
その意見を作ったか聞くぞね。本を読んで
作った意見なんてちゃんおかしい。
自分の意見やないやろからその本を読んで意見を言うならそれが正しいということを証明してからにしろ。
ありがとうございます。
それとね、最後にちょっと
つ言っとくとね、ショート動画がしょ流れるやろ。あれに関しては私はチェックしてないからで、それに関する苦情は受け付けません。諸君があれを切って貼り合わしただけやからね。
それを1つコメントはね、こっちまで届か
んから。だからもしうちに対するコメント
文句があるやろなあ。バカだバカだと言う
んだから。だからそのコメントはとか
ヨットスクールを支援する回というメール
くれれば時間があれば答えるし直接の方が
よく分かるからね。相手がどこが分からん
かが分かる。だからヨッスクルを支援する
会の方にメールをくれね。精神に関する
色々論争があるし、いろんなことを言う人
がおってみんな自分が正しいと言うんだ
からセミナー確実に奇数月に東京名古屋
大阪とやってるからもしそれに参加したい
人数に制限があるもんでヨットスクールを
支援する会塚ヨッスクールを支援する会の
ホームページを見てもらえばでそこに
申し込んでもらえば席は取ります。ただし
満席になったらもうちょっと勘弁願いたい
。
あれはね、消防法によってそこの部屋の人数以上に入れてはいかんのだということをよろしく。
リンクも動画の概要欄にも記載します。